[Music]
Well, hello dear friends. Welcome to our
question and answer program. I'd like to
know. It's a feature that takes place
every week. You send in your questions
and we put them all in order and we
answer them in the order in which we
receive them. Any question that you have
on Bible issues is welcome here at
Secrets Unsealed. I have with me two
distinguished participants which to my
right CA Murray uh who is a regular here
at Secrets Unsealed. It's a pleasure to
have you here. Good to be here. Good to
be with you. And to my left I have
Pastor David Salasar who is in charge of
our Spanish programming here at Secrets
Unsealed and Some TV. It's always a
pleasure to work with you. Thank you
pastor. a blessing for me to be with you
as well. Praise the Lord. And we're glad
that you decided to join us today. We
have some very captivating questions
today that we want to take time to
answer. However, before we do, let me
give you the email address where you can
send your questions to us. You'll see it
on the screen. TV
tvsumtv.org. Once again,
tvsumtv.org. We would be delighted to
receive your questions. We're not going
to start this session without praying
because we need divine guidance. And so
I would ask uh pastor Salasar if he
would pre please pray that the Lord will
be with us in the program. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, thank you once again
for allowing us to come before your
throne of grace and we can come boldly
to ask of you the gift of the Holy
Spirit that we may receive the
instruction and the guidance of your
Holy Spirit that we may receive and be
able to share and speak the answers that
are according to your will and according
to your word. So please be with us now
and we thank you for allowing us to
spend this time together. We pray this
in Jesus name. Amen. Amen. Amen. Well,
before we get uh to our questions, I
want to make an announcement. As
probably many of you know, the general
conference session is this year in St.
Louis, Missouri. And general conference
is going to be from uh July 3 through
July 12. And uh we will be present there
with a goodsiz booth. And um we are
going to do several things there at
general conference session. We are going
to do live I'd like to know programs
there. You'll be able to submit your
questions there at the general
conference session and we will answer
them on the I'd like to know program.
Uh we are also going to do the same with
meustaria sav our Spanish question and
answer program. We will also be taking
questions and we will be answering those
questions live. We're also going to be
doing interviews. You know we have some
u uh correspondents that are going to be
uh going different places and doing
interviews with delegates and with
people who attend the general conference
session. It's going to be a wonderful
experience and so we would encourage you
to come by our booth. Uh our booth is
number 107
uh on the floor of the general
conference exhibit area. So we would be
delighted to have you come by watch a
live program. We're also going to do
Sabbath schools there uh as we do them
for every week. And so it's going to be
a wonderful experience. We invite you to
come by our booth. Okay, enough
advertising. Let's go now to our
questions. Um, we have a first question
and maybe I can have uh CA if you would
read that question um which is sent to
us by Claudia from Canada. Claudia from
Canada. Hello. I'd like hello I'd like
to know team. I have a question. I have
been told that the Catholic Church wrote
the Bible or put together the Bible
after the after the prophets and that
and that thanks to them we that is
Protestants have access to the Bible and
therefore they are and will always be
the church chosen by God. I've tried to
investigate the stand of the SCA church,
7th Adventist Church, on such claims,
but have found no concrete to counter
the claim that the Catholic Church wrote
the Bible. Look forward to hearing from
you. May God continue to bless your
ministry.
Okay. So, who wants to measure in on
this particular question? Did the
Catholic Church write the Bible?
Well, uh, first of all, we have to
remember that the Old Testament were
written by individuals who are, you
know, Moses, the prophets, none of them
were Catholics. None of them understood
or had knowledge of of the church of the
Catholic Church because they were prior
to the formation of the Catholic Church.
So, the Old Testament was definitely
written by Hebrews in the most part of
all of them. Um and the New Testament
was written by also individuals who were
or predated the Catholic Church. You
know, the apostles, the uh the Peter,
Paul, uh all the ones that that made the
books of the New Testament Luke, you
know that, you know, they were all
individuals who are pre- Catholic, you
know, the formation of the Catholic
Church. So to say that the Catholic
Church wrote the Bible is is really
inaccurate. It's completely wrong. Now
what maybe they are trying to imply is
that the Catholic Church put together
the books that make the Bible canon. And
there is some partial truth to that. And
I say partial because uh the Christian
church, the early Christian church, the
church that the Lord Jesus established,
uh it's the one that received the
letters and the gospels and they kept
copies of these gospels. And so uh as as
this church continued to grow and
continued throughout the centuries,
eventually that church, the main core of
the church became the Catholic Church.
So in that regard they can claim to a
certain degree that they were the ones
that organized but it really is not
necessarily the case. Again the Catholic
Church was established as a church as a
power in 50 in 538 or 5080 depending on
the day you look into it. But really the
core the the the cannon the the canon of
the Bible was established in uh the date
was in 397 in the council of cardage
which was finalized as the canon for the
27 books of the new testament and the um
uh 30 39 books of the old testament. So
yeah, that's how then when it was
published. I would add we we the the
Catholic Church didn't really come into
existence until uh the 500s. You can
take 508, 538. The the last person to
write the gospels was John. John
finished his writing just prior to 100
AD. You know, some 95 and 100 those
dates are kicked around. Moses not
Catholic. David not a Catholic. Isaiah,
Jeremiah, not a Catholic. So the idea
that the Catholic Church uh wrote the
Bible uh just is not in league or in
line with history. Yeah. And um we need
to measure Roman Catholic
theology by the Bible that they claim to
have formed.
Uh are they willing to accept for
example that Christ was sacrificed once
for all?
No. Because in the mass they teach that
uh Jesus is sacrificed in every mass.
Yeah. Would they be willing to accept
that there's one intercessor between God
and men, Jesus Christ, the man? No.
Because they believe that priests are
intercessors. Would they be willing to
say that we're supposed to keep the
Sabbath as the day of rest? No. They say
we're supposed to keep Sunday as a day
of rest. Would they be willing to accept
that um only adults should be baptized
and that they should be baptized by
immersion? No. No. because they baptize
infants and they do it by sprinkling. So
let's measure the Adventist the the
Roman Catholic Church by what the New
Testament and the Old Testament say. The
Roman Catholic Church is
totally opposed to sound doctrine that
is found within the scripture that they
claim to have formed. They believe in a
lot of images and saints and you know
and praying for the dead basically right
which contra contrary to the Bible
completely and they have manipulated or
manhandled the ten commandments. Uh so
they certainly have massaged that. Um
it's funny we had this argument just the
last Sabbath we were driving a car
coming back from church and someone was
asking why is uh did some churches have
Christ always on the cross and some have
him off the cross? you know, why the
Catholic Church always put him back on
the cross? And uh we're listening to
some uh thing on the computer there and
the guy was saying, "Well, because in
the mass they take him down off and they
put him when they're done, they put him
back, you know, so he's always on the
cross." Uh
Christians don't have a crucifix. They
have a cross where he is risen, he is
gone, he's not on the cross ever. So the
basic theological tenants of the word of
God are at opposed to many of the
theological tenants of the Catholic
Church. So if they wrote it, then
they're speaking against themselves,
right? Because they don't they disavow
everything that that many other things
that the Bible teaches. You know, one of
my favorite uh undertakings when I
travel to Roman Catholic countries is to
visit as many Roman Catholic churches as
I can because I like to look at their
icons. Yes. At their artwork. I like to
look at their st glass stained windows.
I like to look at their images because
basically that's the theology of the
Roman Catholic Church. Very true. And
and almost
invariably wherever I go you find
Mary
overshadowing Christ. Yes. You know Mary
Mary is the central figure. Absolutely.
That's what they believe. And secondly,
uh Jesus is almost
always on the cross
and he's bleeding and he's suffering. In
Protestant churches, the the cross is
empty. Yes. Because Christ is no longer
on a cross. Christ resurrected from the
dead. Amen. And so Jesus is portrayed
uh in a different way in the 7th day
advenist church and Protestantism than
it is in Roman Catholic theology. Um and
so you know the Roman Catholic Church
claims to have uh formed the Bible uh or
as this question says written the Bible
but their theology is a total
contradiction of the book they claim to
have formed. There you go. Which is your
point. Uh so what do we need to measure
a church by? We have to measure a
church's theology by whether it
harmonizes with the Bible or not. Yeah.
And we have to do that ourselves. You
know, we can't let the pastor or the
priest do it for us. We have to search
the scriptures for ourselves. Another
thing that the reason why they try to
claim that that idea that they have the
the right to the Bible is so that they
can actually have according to their
belief the authority to interpret or to
change the Bible or that they have
bigger authority over the Bible. But
let's just make it you know just common
sense. What has more authority?
something that predates the the you know
the existence of the church and the the
Bible has been predated predates the
Catholic Church by millennium. So it's
it's so sad that individuals sadly and
leaders in in the Catholic Church have
not even understood the true value of
the scriptures as the word of God as the
authority uh the supreme authority of
God on this earth and instead they cling
to traditions to man-made mandates and
laws and have rejected as you well said
pastor rejected the Bible as their
source of authority and doctrine. You
know, it's interesting. Uh, just a few
weeks ago, my wife and I visited a a
local Adventist church for the first
time. We don't get a chance to get to
the local churches. We when we're in
town, we usually go to Fresno Central.
So, we went to a couple another one. And
um, my wife asked me, "Who do who do you
think we got this church from?" You
know, we're know it's an older building.
And I said I looked around. I said, "Oh,
this is this is Catholic. Just look at
the the the stained glass windows."
Because your theology is usually
pictured in the stained glass windows.
And when you see Christ with the little
halo and you see Mary lifted above, I
said this was this was Catholic before
because they they do parade their
theology in in in their in their stained
glass windows and kind of thing. So um I
think both of you are very very correct
and I and and I agree. Um you can't be
the author of something and then go back
and repudiate it, you know, so
thoroughly. So obviously they didn't
they didn't write it because it predates
the formation of the Catholic Church.
Okay, I think we've answered that
question pretty well. Now, let's go to
our next question. It comes from Carl.
And Carl did not give us a location
where he lives. We want to encourage you
to please uh let us know where you're
writing from. Uh it's very helpful to us
to know the reach of our program, where
our program is being seen. Uh this is an
interesting question. When Adam and Eve
were not allowed access to the tree of
life, they eventually died after over
years. How is it that Satan and his
fallen angels have been able to uh to
survive so long after not having access
to the tree of life in heaven? According
to Revelation, they will continue
existence through another thousand
years. Are they feeling any effects yet?
All right. I'm sure they are.
Well, um, that's an interesting
question. I I'd like to start by
answering based on the B Bible. And if
we go to Genesis chapter 2, verses 8 and
N, I I want to make a point here that is
very important. I'm going to read
Genesis 2 8 and 9. It says there, "The
Lord God planted a garden eastward in
Eden, and there he put the man whom he
had formed, and out of the ground the
Lord God made every tree grow that is
pleasant to the sight and good for
food." The tree of life was also in the
midst of the garden, and the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil.
Now, first of all, I think Carl uh is
making an assumption that we don't find
in scripture. uh again u that there's a
tree of life in heaven you know he
mentions here there's a tree of life in
heaven the tree of life was planted for
men on earth uh it was for mankind and
then we if we go in after the fall in
Genesis 3 uh the last chapter there or
the last verse rather uh well the last
three verses notice what it says there
in verse 22 after they have fallen after
they you know the the Lord uh told them
that they were going to be expelled uh
from the from the Garden of Eden. Notice
what it says. And the Lord God said,
"Behold, the man has become like one of
us to know good and evil. And now, lest
he put out his hand and take also the
tree of life and eat and live forever.
Therefore, the Lord sent him out of the
garden of Eden to till the ground from
the which he had taken. and he drove at
the man and he placed care of him at the
east of the garden of Eden and a flaming
sword which turned every way to guard
the way to the tree of life. So we can
see
that as men was expelled from Eden, the
Lord guard the tree of life and the tree
of life stayed on earth in the garden of
Eden until through the spirit prophets
we know until the time of the flood
where the Lord took the garden to
heaven. So what I'm saying with this is
that there is no clear evidence anywhere
in the Bible that declares that in
heaven the angels eat of the tree of
life or there's a tree of life. If there
is, we don't know that. So we're we
would speculate about that particular
situation. So how do the angels live? Um
that is a mystery. You know what type of
how their bodies are composed? What do
they take? We don't know that. But what
we can say is that because of sin there
is a degeneration if you will of the of
of the forms that they had. White speaks
of Satan seeing him with decay
characteristics in his in his frown in
his face. Uh even though he was um angel
of light because of sin because of
rebellion he has now sort of aged or has
you know become you not not as as as
beautiful as he was once. So there is a
decay and whether or not angels need to
eat of a tree of life that's a
speculation and so what we know is that
at least for us for mankind the tree of
life was given as a way for us to extend
life to keep life going but for angels
that is not something that we have a
light on. We don't really have any
information about uh how uh Lucifer who
became Satan and his angels were going
to perpetuate their life uh we do know
that human beings had to continue eating
from the tree of life in order to
continue living but we don't exactly
know uh how the angels perpetuate their
life. Obviously, there must be some
source that they partake of, if we can
use that word, uh to perpetuate their
life, because they are mortal beings.
They're not immortal. They don't they're
not by nature immortal. Their life is
derived from God in some way. Um but the
important point is that we know that uh
Satan and his angels will be destroyed.
Yeah. So they do not have their own
immortal life. It is derived in some
way. But how? Yeah. Yeah. Your guess is
as good as mine. That's the point that
occurred to me that first of all they
are different order of creation than
mankind. Um, one of the things that we
noticed, Adam, Adam Adam lived what, 930
and then died. And then of course the
second group of uh
patriarchs, the the age came down by a
lot. So now you get three score and 10,
you're doing good. You know, my my
mother-in-law lived to 101. And
everybody praise the Lord because she
was she lived a good 101.
Um, so evidently the the lifespan
allotted to to angels is much longer for
whatever reason. They don't burn out as
quickly as as we do. There was a time
when we could get a thousand years. Meth
Methusela 969. Well, now, you know, I'm
I'm 70 plus and I'm feeling it. You
know, uh Ellen White talks about seeing
Satan uh sitting with his hands resting
on his, you know, head resting in his on
his on his chin there. And she says he
sin has beat him up. He can she could
see the effects of sin. She says that
his flesh was hanging hanging loosely
and his forehead receding you know the
whole she so sin has has left it mark
its mark on him but it looks like angels
have to be destroyed rather than dying
on their own and of course the the
hellfire was made for the devil and his
angels. So the the mechanism of the
destruction is in in in uh uh in place.
Some of these things we just have to
wait and see because we don't know
precisely how they regenerate or how
what they what they do. Obviously,
they've been they've been granted much
longer lifespans than than man has. And
uh that's the really only reality that
we have. By the way, that reference to
where Ellen White describes Satan as she
saw him in vision is in early writings
page 152. Exactly. Uh so uh if you want
to check that out, that would be great.
Let's go to our next question. And I
think uh even though we have just uh 3
plus minutes left, we can uh address
this one. Uh it says, I have a question
about Revelation
21:1. And then we have the quotation of
the book of the verse. Then I saw a new
heaven and a new earth, for the first
heaven and the first earth had passed
away, and there was no longer any sea.
When the earth is made new, are there no
more oceans? If so, what happens to all
the dolphins, whales, fish, and other
amazing sea creatures? It would be very
sad if all the beautiful animals which
require an ocean habitat would be lost
forever in God's new world. I appreciate
your wonderful ministry and have learned
so much about the Bible from hearing
your lectures. Um, hope you can help me
understand the meaning and purpose of
this verse. Thanks for all you and your
staff at Secrets Unsealed do to prepare
everyone for the glorious second coming
of our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. God
bless. So, what can we say about there
not being any sea? Does that mean
there's there's not going to be any
marine creatures uh in the earth made
new? Well, pastor, if we go to the verse
that she quotes, you know, remember that
John says, "And I saw a new heaven and a
new earth." meaning that the earth that
he was in or the one that we live in is
passed away and a new one is formed, a
new one is created. And so even though
there's no ocean, the ocean is or
there's no more sea, the idea is not
necessarily that there is no more water
or no more bodies of water to have
animals. But the concept is more
directly linked to the fact of the
separation that the sea makes uh for in
this case John who was in an island of
Padmos away from everyone away from
civilization away from everyone else and
he's making differences that he saw that
the earth was perfect where there's this
unity this harmony there is a sense of a
family and when we go back to revel to
Genesis chapter one in the creation
story we see that God made the seas and
the you know he put the waters into the
seas and then he made them to be filled
with animals and they everything was
made good. So I believe that God will uh
have areas of water large enough for all
these beautiful creatures. There is no
need for us to worry. God would provide
plenty of of of of enough areas for to
have animals that we enjoy to see and
and to Ellen White indicates that there
were bodies of water as Genesis 1 says,
but they were not the vast oceans that
we have today. Uh the vast oceans that
we have today are the result of the
flood. Correct. Correct. And Ellen White
also says that there were rolling hills.
I'm I'm paraphrasing. Rolling hills in
uh the creation originally. There were
no ragged mountains, right? She says the
ragged mountains come as a result of the
flood. So the flood made drastic changes
in this world. So take comfort. There
will be marine creatures in the earth
made new. Well, thank you so much for
joining us today for our program. I'd
like to know. We trust that the answers
we have provided have been a blessing.
Please join us next time where we will
have additional questions. God bless you
and hope to see you in our next program.
[Music]